the jurogan experience you can imagine
if you get your [ __ ] together you could
be talking like biggie and making
everybody look stupid right you know
that [ __ ] crazy one night we was in l.a
and um
it was like we're in hollywood somewhere
and pog had biggie with him and we was
just on stage rapping and [ __ ]
and everybody was freestyling warren g
biggie
park and myself and maybe some video
footage of that
let's see if you can find that
biggie snoop tupac warren g
freestyling in hollywood wow yeah that
[ __ ] was hard
and we didn't really know cuz at the
time
so we was looking at who was this fat
[ __ ] rapper
when he started rapping [ __ ] was like
whenever when them words came out of his
mouth [ __ ] stopped looking at
what he looked like and was like [ __ ] he
hard as [ __ ]
one of my favorite videos in all of
hip-hop is biggie on a corner in
brooklyn when he was 17 years old have
you ever seen that
yeah but see this [ __ ] right here
there's people in the crowd
[Music]
and biggie on stage
b-tip k-dub
[Music]
do you think when it comes to
people right there he wouldn't even own
death row records that's this this is
the crazy part they go biggie right
there
and what year was this 93
he wasn't even on death row records
he was just my homeboy that came through
to [ __ ] with me and he brought cuz woody
see now biggie
[Music]
they got warren g right there
technique
he had an explosive
he on the west coast this is in l.a
how good is his style
he rapping on warren gb
give me some volume jamie
[Music]
see if you can find that video of him
when he was 17 years old on a street
corner
that's one of my favorites because you
see like a dude who's like you know just
a couple of years removed from being a
kid well see people don't even know that
exists right you just gave them some
exclusive [ __ ] right there but it's on
youtube but they don't know what exactly
how many videos here it is this is my
favorite give me some volume
in
he's in front of a grocery store
the rhythm
[Music]
imagine being out there and seeing a 17
year old kid rapping like that you're
like oh it's over
it's over
do you ever smoke regular cigars
nah i don't [ __ ] with those they give me
hair rush
i gotta have my rush imagine someone
being that good at 17 years old
i know a bunch of cats like that
the video we played before only has 4
000 views on it wow that's what i'm
trying to tell you joey 4 000 you're
gonna make this and i'm only reason why
i'm saying is because i seen it one
night on accident i only seen a little
piece of and i was like damn i remember
that night that was like some cool [ __ ]
we had did you know snoop dogg young
snoop dogg before you had long hair
so what is this this one has 4 600 it
says tupac and biggie on stage 1993 rare
just try to find that on youtube and
it'll pop up and that's 4 612 views as
of today i bet you next time we talk
that [ __ ] gonna have 400 some
thousand views
november 11th this is 93 yeah when we
all cool right we all chilling right we
on the west coast tupac brought biggie
with him we rocking we let cod get down
with us we go in the back smoke chill
hang out it's beautiful
when did he go sideways
once pog got shot
when he got shot he felt like they did
it but and this was when he got shot in
new york yeah before he got shot in
vegas yeah and and so he felt like
someone from the west coast was involved
no
or from the east coast right excuse me
yes
and later information came up that
the people that he thought did it had
nothing to do with it so
by him accusing people of it it kind of
set things off and then by him being
bailed out by death world records and
death world records add more gasoline to
the fire and him being a part of the
most gangsterous label in the world that
his opposition didn't want no issues
with right it only egged it on as
opposed to let's find a resolution uh
let's keep making it more of a problem
right
you know in hindsight we should have
been sitting him down saying nah let's
not go after him let's just make great
music and yeah you know you own bail
right now he wasn't even out of jail he
was out on bail when he got killed
it's um it's obviously
you're dealing with giant cultural
influences and and big business too
because the the business of rap is big
business but there's comparisons to that
and what's happening with other
countries there really is yeah man
man but the people can all get along but
joe did you see this do you see how pure
that was yes i did yeah i did we were
all young
i was 22. yeah pock was 22. we was all
the same age so it was like this is us
at 22 years old being young mc's
competitive you see the spirit he was
rapping when he was rapping like he was
battling the same way he was rapping on
the corner right same spirit but that's
what hip-hop was like we and we enjoy
when somebody could come and hold his
own yes
but what's really crazy is if that's
1993
that is
at the very most
a year old art form
15 at the moment 15 15 at most yeah 15.
like where it really emerges
right so within 15 years
you have
from
almost no influence
to almost the most influence
and
depending on whether a month that was
either i just caught the case or i
hadn't caught the case
and the way i'm looking i don't know it
don't look like i caught a case
wow just by the way i'm moving yeah i'm
looking at my spirit in my body am i
right you're not thinking about it yeah
yeah and when i caught the case all that
kind of [ __ ] was over with right
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify